it really does walk like him doesn't it
for those of you listening on the audio
podcast that was Joe Biden's head on
Elon musk's new Tesla robot and uh it's
got that kind of stilted Joe Biden esque
walk for you I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Rubin report it's January 31st 20124
January's gone already man just where
does the time go we are live streaming
on Rumble YouTube and locals postgame
show Ruben report.
locals.com and we have a big program for
you so let's dive right into it I want
to talk first about uh this interview
that Russell Brand uh did with Tucker
Carlson it's his first interview since
these sort of crazy sexual assault
allegations came out that as far as I
know have not really gone anywhere but
Russell although he's been doing his own
show and I I've actually been on his
show since then he hasn't talked much uh
on other people's shows since and he got
into a whole thing about what really is
happening here these days because as the
truth is bursting forth on the internet
and the nonsense from the mainstream
media keeps trying to push everything
down I think more and more people are
seeing something uh and he hit something
it's going to we'll start with this clip
actually uh you know I always talk about
that sort of thin veneer of
progressivism there's it sort of feels
nice on the outside if you don't think
about it for too long it's kind of good
and then if you just peel back that then
veneer then you see something kind of
nasty and Russell had a nice take in a
similar fashion uh to what's happening
with the authoritarian governments that
we are seeing rise all over the place
and big Tech and the rest of it that in
the old days we thought it was like a
boot on our neck but now it's kind of
got a little paint on it and it's a
little shiny and a little glittery but
the results are still the
same but it seems to me that
authoritarianism now is being
deliberately veiled in a the Insidious
language of care concern safety and
convenience it seems to me that we are
in a time where we Lurch from one crisis
to another that the crisis is always
used to legitimize certain Solutions and
a doile or terrified public is willing
to participate in the proposed solutions
that usually involved giving up their
freedom we are continually being invited
to give up our freedom in exchange for
safety or convenience and it seems that
this process is radically escalating and
I feel that this is something that we
will see yet more of in the coming year
like we're being prepped groomed primed
for war is coming that we're being kept
in a state of constant anxiety in order
to induce compliance that the ongoing
stoking of cultural tension is to ensure
people don't begin to recognize that
actually we have far more in common with
one another than we do with these
curious sets of establishment interests
that seem to be Transcendent of national
democracy to to be explicit I'm talking
about organizations like the who NATO
the WF and their astonishing influence
these think tanks and apparently
independent organizations who are not
independent when you look at where they
get their money big farmer or the
government or the military industrial
complex or the kind of people they
employ people from deep agencies such as
the FBI and CIA that have extraordinary
Affinity with the Legacy Media and their
ongoing agenda so what I suppose I'm
sensing is that totalitarianism now will
not bear the inflections or Aesthetics
of the 20th century militarism guys in
medals with mustaches thumping their
fists on a desk we be calmly told what
with by gentlemen with beautifully
quered hair or elegantly speaking ladies
that just for our safety and just for
our convenience we will be returning to
our homes and anyone that has an
audience or a base or an ability to
communicate with people to disrupt those
types of narratives will be identified
and woo lordy lordy he said a lot there
okay so let's unpack some of that I
think uh actually most of what he
covered there is exactly what I've been
trying to lay out on this show for quite
some time right that's why the
progressive thing has has figured out a
way to take down so much of our system
they didn't do it with you know dressed
up like Nazis and saying mean things
they did it under the guise of diversity
and equity and tolerance all of these
nice things while they actually were the
ones that were calling for you to be
locked in your house and forced to be
vaccinated and mandates and everything
else so I I completely agree with
Russell that there has been a giant test
being run I I don't know exactly how the
strings are pulled but Co feels like it
was just a test could we get a whole
bunch of people to not go to Grandma's
funeral could we get kids to rat out
their parents uh could we get people to
stay at home and eat take out food and
get fat while if they had just gotten a
little bit of sun it might have helped
with the virus like could we get people
to literally be fired from their job if
they don't get injected with our
experimental vaccine and by the way
we're going to have to change the
technical definition of a vaccine
because this thing is not a vaccine as
we had known vaccines to be for at least
100 years uh before that and then of
course you throw in the media part of it
which of course he's right that we've
shown you that video many times that
compilation video if you watch NBC ABC
CBS CNN Fox all the rest of them and
they're brought to you by fizer while
they're talking about vaccine mandates
and all of the rest of it so there's
been this giant machine that has been
kind of screwing with all of us a bunch
of us now are kind of waking up you can
also then connect that to why big Tech
wants to silence so many people because
big Tech is connected to all that I
don't think any of this is some like
Grand conspiracy I don't think any of
this is really uh I don't think any of
this is really out there to be quite
honest I think it is actually just
something that you have to acknowledge
and then figure out how do you how do
you operate within that system right
because I I don't otherwise like I don't
know what what are you going to do then
ultimately it'll be three years from now
and you will be eating bugs out of a
bucket and John krey will be flying
private eating Japanese A5 wagu which by
the way I bought a Japanese A5 wagu this
weekend and Justin had a little bit and
the kid likes the good meat all right uh
let's shift over a little bit to
something that happened during Co that
illustrates exactly uh what Russell is
talking about perfectly uh you may
remember this I think we played this
once during covid this is an Australian
ad so an Australian ad from the
government scare the hell out of people
during covid now remember he was talking
about how these the guys will have nice
quaffed hair and the women will speak
really nicely as they're pushing you
authoritarianism what's the easiest way
to do that scare people and then they
will do it to
[Music]
themselves authorized by the Australian
government canra authorized by this
Australian government canra I mean you
see the type of fear right I could play
four gajillion videos roughly of how
they did that to all of us six feet
social distance all of this nonsense
right only so many people can go into a
store at a time people yelling at each
other over masks and all of those things
but they were doing it for you right and
that's the distinction he's trying to
make that's very different than a bunch
of Nazi foot soldiers walking into town
and and you know murdering people and
everything else that's kind of the way
we think of that authoritarianism right
the boot on the neck they're going to
come in and someone's going to be a
little bit different and they'll just
kill them there might be something a
little more subtle that they're doing
and it's kind of a thing that that
they've done in almost every dystopian
sci-fi movie bit more from Russell on
how the intellectual class the very same
people who were telling you to do all
these things that didn't work and get
injected with stuff and all that uh they
don't really care about you weird wild
stuff there's no question that iise in
um nationalism is an understandable
response to rampant globalism but the
ongoing sort of finger pointing and
condemnation of ordinary people I
identify with I recognize it because I
grew up in those communities
professional met Metropolitan people
don't like workingclass people don't
like Ordinary People and now they've
found a way to legitimize their hatred
oh they're all disgusting they're all
racist look at them in their Maga hats
look at them with their white van and
their flags look at them with their
perspectives with their unearned views
and their belches and their beer it's a
kind of legitimization of a loathing of
the people that are most connected to
the nation people that generally
speaking a couple of generations ago
were asked to sacrifice the lives of
their sons and daughter for the for the
idea of nation an idea that they're now
being told doesn't exist
yeah yeah and we're going to illustrate
some of that uh after this ad in just a
second but I I do want to note that it's
important when you see see two guys like
that sitting down in America today and I
keep talking about how these you know
it's not really left forus right anymore
and it's mostly it's mostly it's mostly
authoritarian versus libertarian and I
don't mean you're a card carrying
shellack member of the libertarian party
uh but it's do you believe in
centralized Authority which of course
lends itself to globalism and that there
really won't be nation states they'll be
sort of the world economic Forum layer
and they'll have their yearly meetings
and they'll tell the Nations what to do
and a lot of people will just say thank
you sir may I have another or do you
believe in more of a Libertarian outlook
on life which would lead to functioning
nation states which is what we've had
basically for the last hundred or so
years uh and that you would make some
choices over your life and and that
really is what the Divide is but there
is there seemingly is a disdain remember
when we showed you a bunch of those
videos from the world economic Forum
last week and you see these people John
car is the easiest one to talk about who
flies on a private jet all the time you
also may remember what was it two months
ago testifying fing under oath that he
didn't have a private jet and then when
he was questioned further oh it turned
out to be his wife's private jet so they
want all of the stuff they will eat
their Japanese A5 wagu they will eat
their fagra and then they will have you
eating lab grown meat and all of the
rest of it right that is the disconnect
and we'll show you a couple examples of
how they uh proliferate that throughout
the mainstream media in just a sec but
let me talk to you guys about the
wellness company guys recent clusters of
respiratory illnesses in northern China
alongside outbreaks of what's being
referred to as white lung syndrome in
the US are scattered across headlines
right now drawing attention to the
importance of being prepared for medical
emergencies with close to 90% of
pharmaceuticals in the US being produced
outside of the country what happens when
the next Global crisis strikes I mean
could this ad be more on point countries
clamp down on exports they stockpile the
price of drugs rise and the pharmacy
shelves in America become empty and this
is already starting to happen you guys
have heard me talk about the wellness
company before but when we're staring
tearing down the barrel of Times Like
These their medical emergency kit is a
musthave the wellness company is home to
Dr Peter McCulla Dr Drew Pinsky and
truth-telling doctors who are rooted in
their commitment to building a parallel
Health Care system and empowering you to
take control of your health in a time
when over 40% of Americans say they
would avoid a doctor or Hospital unless
it was a catastrophic situation the
wellness company's medical emergency kit
provides a solution this handy little
kit includes eight potentially
life-saving medications for you to keep
on hand along with a guide book for safe
use this medical emergency kit includes
emergency antibiotics antivirals
antiparasitics like amoxicilin zpac and
icin to help keep you and your family
safe in the face of natural disasters
supply chain shortages or medical
emergencies like wh longer co go to tww
C.H Ruben and grab your medical
emergency kit to save 15% off your order
and now back to me so what is it that
Russell Brandon and Tucker Carlson are
talking about there that is bringing
people together right you've got Russell
Brand a lefty his entire life now he's
he's woken up a bit and let's say he's
come a little more Center he's more into
the Freedom Movement now he's
understanding the problems with the left
and identity politics you have Tucker
Carlson who's firmly on the right but on
the populist side of that and then so
it's it's a movement of the people right
it's it's sort of the people against the
elite and then you can you can really
widen this thing when I show you these
videos of Joe Rogan who is a lefty his
whole life or you see somebody like
Robert F Kennedy Jr who no longer can be
a Democrat because of everything mostly
related to co and then seeing the
corruption in the party you see Bill
Maher fighting against his own side like
you see how the old Republican machine
has now completely basically been taken
over by trumpism that is a signal of
something right so what is it that is
causing so many people to wake up well
partly what it is is that the mainstream
media has lied about so many things for
so long and finally we've exposed enough
of it that people are going well boy
there are some problems here now I want
to show you how they they sort of hate
you at that Elite level right the elites
sort of just kind of hate you and that's
exactly what Russell was talking about
here is Joy bear from The View do we
have the uh there you go this next clip
shows a certifiably crazy person Joy
bear explaining that the rise of trump
uh is of course kind of like the rise of
Hitler that is true that's what I'm
trying to say here but the man doesn't
take it because doesn't it make it more
funny they made fun of Hitler Charlie
chapler made fun of Hitler 1940 by 1945
millions and millions of people Everyone
Else the audience needs to laugh the
people need to laugh I don't I don't
care care I'm not checking on TR I need
everyone else to be but because he's so
thin skinned isn't it just funnier when
he's M no but it makes him so angry
angry I don't know what he's going to do
next I mean make a joke about him and
he'll annihilate the whole world yes
he'll annihilate the whole world the guy
who again preco we can all criticize him
on the co stuff although for the most
part he left it to the states he he did
a some screwy stuff okay fine nobody's
perfect uh but was giv us the Abraham
Accords was giving us some at least
talks with North Korea Russia was quiet
there was no invasion of Ukraine but
they they ramp this up and really what
they're ramping up uh is is the fear so
that they can stay in control so when
Russell talks about these sort of
Metropolitan intellectual Elites he's
talking about the joy bayar types he's
talking about how you just look what the
machine produces it produces a show like
The View where they have you know four
or five lefties and then just one pet
Republican or or pet conservative and
how does that how does that give you a
snapshot of what of what America really
is it isn't but they don't really want
you to see what America really is
because they don't like a lot of the
people in America uh here's Sarah Hines
that's a that's for you Mom I'm saying
her name the blonde lady on The View who
my mom always tells me she's not
completely insane
that's an awful lot of credit for me to
give one of these ladies uh here she is
explaining how when Donald Trump was
President she had to hide the news from
her children do you know what my child
can't watch news when you turn it on I
literally had to hide news for four
years while Donald Trump was in because
as they're learning what a president of
the United States is I didn't want to
say yeah and that's him right there so I
couldn't even announce the president
until Biden and vice president Harris oh
well Sarah do you talk to your child
about how Joe Biden has dementia and
everyone knows it and that Barack Obama
is really running this Administration or
some Machinery behind Joe Biden or do
you talk about his son the crack addict
who had the job at barisma and then we
end up uh in this war in you like you
talk about all that stuff he always
sniffing girls hair that's a little
weird do you talk about that stuff it's
also this thing about uh we that they
had to hide information from their
children because of Donald Trump I
remember we were we're at a family thing
this is at the maybe year two of trump
presidency like so like pre-co but like
the height of the lunacy and craziness
and everyone's fighting and I'm at this
big family thing like 30 of us and I
asked and everyone's arguing about
everything which my family used to be
quite good at that um arguing and then
just putting everything down dessert and
we're and we're all good so I I thought
you know what let me ask my nephew my
oldest nephew he was about 10 at the
time I asked my nephew I said what do
what do you think about Donald Trump
because you can see he's the oldest of
the generation he was kind of looking at
the adult table like can I get in on
this I think it was 10 or 11 said what
do you think about Donald Trump he goes
well he's got crazy hair and he wears a
red tie and I was like yes and that is
better political analysis than you would
hear on CBS or ABC or anything else the
idea that children are being broken by
all this stuff children are being broken
by being locked at home children are
being broken by being forced to be
injected with things and not being able
to socialize normally and all
that anyway uh what's the other thing
that they do the other thing that they
do is they create all of the problems
like a border problem let's say we have
a massive border problem you know it I
know it everyone knows it know it
they're finally admitting it now but
what do they do they never look at maybe
their policies that have caused this
problem they give you Donald Trump here
is Elizabeth Warren who is what is she
164th Native American if I'm not
mistaken one
268 1
1,64 American Indian uh Elizabeth Warren
uh blaming Donald Trump for the current
open border crisis is Donald Trump
president right now I can't remember no
I don't think the real threat here is
the one you identified just now and that
is Donald Trump who says there's a
problem at the border but he wants that
problem to get worse to continue to be a
problem so that he can run on it next
November that is another example of
Donald Trump trying to put his own
political interests ahead of the
interests of the United States he says
he's out there cheering for an economic
recession knowing it would put people
out of work knowing it would cost people
their savings but that's what he wants
because he thinks it will help him come
November you know this is a man who puts
himself first and puts the United States
of America way behind that so incredible
first off just on a funny note like this
thing with her being Cherokee or
whatever it's 10 Generations ago so
she's 1
1,64 Cherokee yet she wrote that she was
part Cherokee on a job application to
get a job at Harvard which she did get
like try to think of like the layers of
evil psychosis with that woman a woman
who by the way is a communist uh who
also how much is Elizabeth Warren worth
she's worth at least 20 million we'll
we'll check 60 million a cool 60 mil
nothing like a communist worth 60 M
anyway in terms of what she said right
there first off could it possibly be
true I'll try to give the devil his due
could it possibly be true that in Donald
Trump's mind right now that because he's
running for president and the worse the
Border gets the more it helps him that
he kind of doesn't want the Border
problem solved right now that actually
is true like that that actually is true
right if Biden tomorrow solve the
problem at the border people would be
like oh my God Joe Biden is competent
the Democrats actually did fix something
I guess maybe we don't have to vote for
Trump so I'll Grant her that however
blaming the problem on Trump and we'll
get to some numbers in just a sec is
completely bananas because they were the
ones calling Trump racist when he wanted
to build a wall Trump came into office
only really because of immigration so it
is not Donald Trump's fault he may in
the most calculating political way not
want it solved exactly right now which
that's just the nature of how kind of
evil politics is but that's a separate
issue uh MAA over there on the Morning
Joe show and these two are married which
is just very bizarre to me uh they
continued sort of on this theme last
night Trump encouraged lawmakers to do
nothing on the border to keep the Border
open Trump encouraged them to let fentel
continue to flood in and let illegal
immigrants continue to stream across the
border that's what Donald Trump said and
Republicans are so weak they're going to
do it they're going to side with fentel
and illegal immigrants instead of a
bipartisan tough border security Bill
anyone on social media and wrote
incorrectly we are better off not making
a
deal uh sorry sorry I was trying to
write down all the crap there I
literally just wrote the word crap first
off look there's the word crap it's
there um first off the the idea that
that signing this bipartisan but first
off Donald Trump's not president that's
number one okay so that's first off
Donald Trump is not president right now
that's one thing Joe Biden is President
secondly the bipartisan deal we went
through the numbers on this over the
last two days here the deal itself lets
in up to 5,000 illegals a day 5,000 time
365 days a year thanks to Brock's Trust
calculator on his phone over there is
1.8 million people illegal so you have
all the legals and then you they will
also allow they're going to sign a bill
that will allow for 1.8 million illegals
that makes no then it's not a law in the
first place so Donald Trump in that Tru
social uh tweet or post is actually
correct you don't sign the deal you do
not sign the deal by the way we will be
in uh DC on Monday Rumble is opening
Studios on Monday and our Tuesday show
uh will be live from DC and we're going
to be sitting down who do we have we
have Ram Paul we have Ted Cruz I think
we're working chip Roy Thomas Massie Mar
Martha Marsha Blackburn and I'm going to
question all of them on this because
Congress is in session right now and for
those on the Senate side of this thing
you if you are a republican you cannot
sign this thing if you sign this thing
you're basically signing America's death
warrant and that that's largely what
most of these people seem to do but I I
definitely will put the pressure on them
so Donald Trump's not president right
now Joe Biden is it's also interesting
that suddenly they're allign
acknowledging there is a problem when
Donald Trump was saying there was a
problem years ago when we had much less
of a problem uh they said it was because
he was racist now the problem is much
worse for months and months and months
they haven't been acknowledging the
problem it's only in the last say two to
three weeks that the mainstream media
finally because of shows like this and
Rogan and Tucker and everything else
because we've all been talking about
this and more and more people are tuning
into these shows that they're finally
like boy there is a border problem we're
going to have to start talking about and
who can we blame oh let's get to the
orange man let's move over to the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC because Joy Reed she's been back
on the Ruben report doet it's very
exciting blonde Joy Reed uh she brought
on the former director of Hispanic media
for Hillary that's a title for you uh to
talk about how if Texas secures its own
border that's actually an act of
lawlessness this massive resistance it
sounds like the old southerners who said
that we will resist integration by any
means necessary that chip Roy L language
how does that read inside of the Latino
Community I mean it's it's very it's
very simple know if you're the
Republican party you're you're allegedly
the party of laws and Order and you're
essentially telling local authorities to
break the law no so I think once again
going into this image of you know who is
the party of Law and Order and who is
the party for democracy I think that's
where we all have to highlight the
hypocrisy regardless of the politics
they're essentially telling people how
does that read in the Latina community
bibl like she's such a
pandering woman
um you know it's interesting because the
the Latinos the Latinos that work in or
that live in these border towns they are
largely breaking Republican because they
in most cases came here legally and the
ones who didn't come here legally are
trying to figure out that pathway to
citizenship and it's their communities
who are being hit the hardest so I
guarantee you this we Flash forward 10
years from now the most rightwing anti-
illegal immigration segment of the US
population is going to be the legal
Latino population Latino like
pandering um the Democrats weren't
always insane they were probably like if
you would have analyzed closely you
would have been like something ain't
right with these people but they weren't
always completely absolutely insane uh
and I'd like to show you this video of
Joe Biden this is just uh months before
he won that election which is still just
mind-blowing uh this is in August of
2020 uh acknowledging that what Trump
was doing on the border was actually
working Mr Vice President under the
Trump Administration Asylum has
virtually ended ice detention centers
are pactic empty uh your new plan calls
for reversing president Trump's harsh
plan but won't that restart a brand new
border crisis I mean what what would you
do with all those people in camps now
waiting in
Mexico it it will if we don't do it well
we don't reach out to the to the uh
communities that are willing to the
charitable communities that will come in
and help and and in addition to us
spending millions of dollars providing
for Access access for judges access for
Asylum folks to be on the border to move
quickly because if we just say okay all
done we I've withdrawn the order you're
going to have a crisis on the other side
of the Border Trump migrant protection
protocols you know remain in Mexico
progam I mean okay so that's before the
election him saying oh there's no crisis
he's fully acknowledging there's no
crisis like the border is working and
everything else and then basically it's
interesting because he's kind of
speaking out of both sides of his mouth
there because basically he's saying but
you know you can't just let everybody in
we're just going to need more judges and
blah blah blah and it's like well that's
not quite right either because that just
means you're going to let in a whole
bunch of people now subsequently we've
done both we have brought more judges
down there we let more people in Legally
but the real issue is that we've just
opened the doors and let everyone in
illegally here's Biden just a few months
later one of his first orders as
president February of 21 signing an
executive order to remove all of those
Trump policies that he acknowledged in
the video we just showed you were
actually working today I'm going to sign
a few executive orders um
uh to strengthen immigration system
building on uh the executive actions I
took on day one to protect dreamers and
and the Muslim ban and to better manage
our borders and that's what these uh
three different uh executive orders are
about yep so he reversed all of the
things that he once at least as a
candidate acknowledged were actually
working and then what are the
repercussions of that here's the Texas
border last
week
I have to tell you guys I I don't care
why those people are at the border
personally I don't care we cannot have
just a gajillion people wandering in and
again largely men largely fighting a
where are the children where are the old
women where are the wives but either way
we cannot have this and you might go
Dave Dave let them go to Texas we don't
really care about those Texas border
towns for God's sakes we've got to
protect Martha's Vineyard that's the
place we've got to protect let them stay
in Texas well you know what they get to
Texas they get to Arizona and then they
get in buses or they get on planes and
they go all across the country take a
look at what was once one of the most
beautiful cities in the United States
this is Denver Colorado just two or 3
days ago this is in Denver Colorado look
at all of these migrants where do you
think they're coming from where do you
think they're coming
from this is absolutely crazy what the
heck
man can barely get through this Street
here oh my
God what the heck
if you were a mom and you lived in
Denver and you were uh walking your baby
with the stroller would you feel safe
walking down that
street who are these people what are
they doing there what are they doing
with that big van there are they cooking
meth who the hell knows but you might
say Dave those hippies those pot smoking
hippies in Denver they deserve it at
least this isn't happening in our best
cities at least this isn't happening in
the number one city in the world it
couldn't be happening in New York could
it well we've shown you a lot of videos
of what's going on in New York uh this
is actually quite depressing but it's
worth it's just worth seeing here is a b
a group of uh of migrants just
unleashing all hell beating the crap out
of two police officers in Times Square
yesterday so you can see what they're
doing here uh I
mean it's like who are these people what
are they doing they have no fear for the
police officers no will be arrested and
if if they if they detain one of them
they will be released tomorrow look at
these people look at these people what
is going on here it is not racist or
bigoted or anything else to say these
are bad people and they've got to get
the hell out of this country and
somebody's got to do it and it's frankly
amazing that the Democrats now again and
it's only because we've all been
applying the pressure are acknowledging
they're a problem they're blaming Trump
for the problem but they're at least
acknowledging there's a problem so you
want to see the scale of the problem
it's actually quite incredible uh
there's this great Twitter account it's
Koka the great uh and he put up some of
the numbers related to Illegal
immigration I'm not going to read all
these but if you go all the way back to
2010 you can see about 460,000 people
and then it's 340 360 but and we're
bouncing basically in the 300s and the
400s until 2019 right before who was it
oh yes the orange man then it jumps to
860,000
illegals uh and then of course
subsequently you see what has happened
in these last two years including last
year alone
3.2 million illegals we know if you look
at those last three years under Joe
Biden that is over 6 million illegals
it's it's basically 10x in about 13
years right from about
300,000 to about 3 million in a year
what country what system can tolerate
that none none actually none Elon Musk
gets it here's what he tweeted in
response to that the United States is is
being overwhelmed and again guys for any
of you that were on the internet 10
years ago this is exactly what was
happening in Spain and in Italy and in
France and in the UK and particularly in
Germany this they were watching their
borders be overrun and nobody did
anything and they have much bigger
problems now because they have islamists
and terrorist supporters taking over
their cities right so I don't know I
suppose if we don't do anything about it
that's what we will have I live in the
Free State of Florida I think we're
going to be okay here uh but but it is a
crappy crappy situation to say the least
the other problem is that let's say you
were trying once again you were just
trying to be the nicest person possible
we should let in as many people we
should help them we should take our
resources and give to them and
everything else well the whole purpose
of the United States of America is that
you assimilate into the culture of the
United States of America what what did
we always say what did we all learn in
third fourth grade we learned about the
Melting Pot of America which was very
different than what they had in Europe
and what very different really from
every country preamer which was the idea
that you come here you bring your
cultures your food your languages all
those things and those aren't the
primary thing anymore they fold into the
Melting Pot they melt into that that pot
that soup that creates something
delicious and wonderful and that's based
in Freedom and individual liberty and
all of those things but you don't forget
all of your traditions and everything
else you don't forget where you're from
you don't forget your family and all
that but you you have it fold into this
beautiful thing that is America the
problem now is that the progressives and
and the elitists who will tell us that
this place is evil and it's racist and
its founding was awful and everything
else they don't even like this place in
the first place so they want now to turn
this country into the types of countries
that most of our ancestors had to flee
from who is an incredible example of
that well there's at least one of them
actually several but she's the best uh
several examples of that in uh the
United States Congress here is Minnesota
Hamas caucus member ilhan Omar uh at
this Somali conference from these videos
that have gone viral over these last
couple
days
Hass m in
[Applause]
Minneapolis special
relationship
Somalia that M
with is that woman is she a
congresswoman from Somalia or from
Minnesota I'm a little confused with by
I'm a simple man I might have
misunderstood who she is exactly she
talks about the president of Somalia uh
who calls her girl and she calls him
Uncle uh we played some clips from you
uh yesterday about how she's talking
about how it's the Somalian job in the
United States to make America work for
Somalia I mean this is this is
absolutely insane what's going on with
this woman uh here's just a bit more
because she keeps referring to Somalia
as our nation our nation again she is a
sitting congresswoman fairly certain
that America is our
nation 2016 is election
cycle and you guys have the ability to
make an impact on where our nation is
headed not only here in the United
States but even in our nation back home
our nation back home um she would love
to turn America into Somalia a country
that she fled and then became a super
powerful influential person in America
she fled the oppression that she had in
Somalia if you want to see the stark
contrast like the 180 difference between
IL Han Omar I would recommend that you
watch any video I've interviewed her
many times and she's a dear friend Aion
hery Ali who's also a refugee from
Somalia who now has become one of the
great Freedom Fighters across the world
she's a true Angel who understands what
she fled and why we shouldn't be
importing that here but ilhan Omar is
importing it here and uh don't take my
words for it remember her line on
911 care was founded after
911 because they recognized that some
people did something some people did
something some people did something they
killed about 2,000 Americans I lived in
New York City uh during 9/11 what she's
referring to there is care uh which is
the council for Arab Islamic relations
or something that supposedly deals with
islamophobia which is not even a real
term uh that she was mostly concerned
that people were going to say mean
things about Muslim people she shows no
concern for the people who were just
killed some people did some did
something uh just just a tiny bit more
on her because this is just absolutely
out of control she just the N wokeness
account that we reference here a lot
mentioned that she just retweeted this
person so uh I don't even have to read
her tweet there but the person that she
retweeted mufio IB Islan okay uh this is
one of his tweets there is power with
numbers breed like rats and establish
Global dominance inshah the 21st century
will see the great rise of Islam glory
be to
Allah and she's retweeting this person
does this strike you as someone that
should be in the Congress of the United
States uh well it doesn't strike Ronda
santis that way and here's what he
tweeted expel from Congress denaturalize
and Deport I want to show you one more
tweet on this because uh Liz wheeler
who's a friend of mine friend of the
show uh she wrote this I thought it was
quite good republicans in Congress
expelled George Santos but not ilhan
Omar and people ask me why as a
conservative I despise the Republican
party so much right and you guys get it
what do I often say here it's like I
consider myself a Florida Republican
that's a very specific thing to me that
is connected to freedom and liberty and
competent government and all of that but
the wider party like they have such an
opportunity right here why did George
Santos get booted out of Congress again
does anyone even remember he had
colorful socks or something he made up
something on his resume meanwhile we
have her and they're doing absolutely
nothing by the way were any of those
clips of ilhan Omar on CNN or MSNBC no
why not that's kind of curious so the
point is we need to speak up the time is
now right it is now we don't want to end
up where Europe is now but we will end
up there if we don't do anything about
it uh Elon Musk who again has been
leading the charge on this in that he
has opened up X so that we able to see
more and more of these videos uh he had
a a good tweet on what's going on in
Denver we just showed you that video
from Denver and he retweeted it he wrote
If Denver is having trouble with 40,000
illegals how will they handle the next
400,000 the illegal influx is growing
exponentially and just exceeded babies
born in America last month did you catch
that last part I think we might have
referenced the chart was going around
about a month ago where there are now
more illegals coming into the country
than Americans having babies play that
out do some basic math I know math is
racist but you do that over time do you
think we might end up a little bit more
like Somalia do you want to live in
Somalia no neither do I so we have to
wake up Americans of all political
stripes and that gets us back to where
we started at the top that you now have
a lefty like Russell bran sitting down
with a righty like Tucker Carlson and
going there's a whole bunch of
here AR we may feel different things on
abortion or this or that but but we are
acknowledging what the actual problem is
uh and the more people acknowledge the
actual problem they might start voting
in a way that that Elite Class is not
going to be happy about here's Joe Rogan
with Colin Noir on why poor people in
Chicago poor and black and brown people
will probably be voting for Donald Trump
this time around I think it has a lot to
do with Trump because you know when he
was running his campaign he was running
a lot of it based on the idea he was
going to build that Wilden border and so
that became that became a separation
point for a lot of people in country
with respect to what side they fell on
and I think there's there's a particular
party in this country that utilized it
as a as a lightning rod to create that
level of division and so I think they're
kind of trying to reestablish that again
which is one of the things is even more
gangster about Abbott sending people to
Chicago sending people to New York cuz
in Chicago they're like get these people
out and the people that live in Chicago
the poor people Chicago like this is
bull these people getting money they're
getting they they're getting all this
help they're getting food they're
getting all this stuff that we don't
have yeah people literally in the place
who live there their whole lives and
then all a sudden these people sneak in
and they're getting this special
treatment you get it Rogan gets it Colin
gets it you know why do I show you these
clips of Rogan all the time it's not
like he needs the promotion it's because
he's just he's basically a pot smoking
mushroom eating libertarian UFC guy who
has been smashed in the face like they
took a cast iron pan and they bashed him
in the face with reality and suddenly
he's going boy I guess none of this
Lefty stuff makes sense anymore and I
think many many people feel that so the
question is what will happen in this
next election can this it's not a
political party can this movement that's
Loosely based on freedom that is told
that it's racist and homophobic but
actually isn't can it coales around
something that something actually seems
to be Donald Trump right now for all his
flaws like he is the thing that
represents the way out of this that's
just kind of where we're at so now we'll
go full circle here here's Russell on
Tucker uh talking about what this new
Coalition could kind of look like for me
what we need to see is an emergence of a
different type of populism that
transcends the boundaries of left and
right these things are happening
organically and naturally anyway and
what I think is happening is I perhaps
it's odd isn't it because the internet
is ultimately a creation of the military
clearly they didn't accurately
understand that whilst it was going to
be a brilliant means for control and
clearly that's one of the wars that's
being fought now it is also a tool for
informing and Awakening and I think that
we're at this Crux point which way is it
going to go are people going to wake up
to the reality that we are being
confronted with or are we going to sort
of nervously cling on to the idea that
somehow through comfort and panaceas we
might hold on to some old life well the
answer to that question is up to you I
suspect in blue cities and blue States
and places where progressives have taken
over and and brainwashed people and
everything else they will live in a
society that will largely be based on oh
man up top said something guess we can't
go out today and then there will be
other places that will be bastions of
Freedom largely red States where people
will live the way they wish to live
they'll probably grow a little bit more
of their food and take care of
themselves a little bit more and it
might be a little more messy but that's
kind of how it's going to break down and
in some ways that's already happened and
then of course the question that sits
alongside that is how does the internet
remain free how does our ability if if
we're all going in our different
directions what keeps us actually as the
United States of America uh if the
federal government will not do its basic
duties like protect the border and then
the states have to will the states start
Waring with other states because for
some reason New York which is being
overrun by illegal immigrants doesn't
want Texas to do the very freaking job
that the federal government won't do a
lot of problems lot of problems but uh I
think we can come up with some solutions
and I guess uh we'll continue to work on
it guys part one of my interview with Dr
Drew we did it in person right here
yesterday uh we'll be up later today the
full things on Ruben report. locals.com
any moment now uh we do have a new
Twitter account uh Ruben report show if
you want to get clips of the program
directly to spread across the universe
uh we've got a postgame show Ruben
report. locals.com uh coming up in about
30 seconds uh we do in case you didn't
realize it already if you were watching
on Instagram we show the first 5 minutes
of every show Ruben report on Instagram
then we jump everybody over uh to locals
Rumble etc etc we leave you with uh a
little Joe Biden a little taste let's
say of Joe Biden ciao today the White
House invites you to enter a new contest
called lunch without Joe Biden it's a
way for supporters to enjoy a relaxing
lunch without Joe Biden going on and on
with one of his stories like the time
his wife Jill got a bad haircut or the
one about his dog Dutch and the squirrel
he chased it takes about 45 minutes to
tell and in the end the squirrel gets
away dear God enter now go to lunch
without Joe biden.com let's do
[Music]
this